welcome to swipe on the way the YouTube
stars playing for a living an engineer
really gets his project off the ground
and this little guy is 30 but still on
for we've got the new super mario game
in this week's review here's something
you might not know about gaming the
industry is worth more than 50 billion
pounds with predictions that are after
70 billion within the next couple of
years and gaming success isn't all about
the playing people are clocking up
billions of hours just watching here's
Chris to explain hey how's going Bruce
my name is Pierre meet Felix Kjellberg
AKA PewDiePie with over 39 million
subscribers he runs the most viewed
YouTube channel in your world look at it
so smooth it features videos have been
playing his favorite games along with
his own style of commentary last year he
made 4.8 million pounds mostly through
online ads and there are others who
capitalized on this lucrative market
Ashley Ashley Marie is a British gamer
based in LA her speciality is Minecraft
and her video views are in the tens of
millions when I started this I didn't
actually expect to make a living out of
this just because when I was younger I
was kind of like that weird awkward kid
that nobody wanted to be friends with
and then it's just kind of crazy
watching like my channel grow and also
me as a person grow and it's kind of
crazy knowing that I can actually live
off youtube gaming events like this one
in London give fans the opportunity to
see their idols in the flesh but what's
the fun in watching people play game
rather than just playing them yourself I
just love the commentary
do well so pain games are so funny when
the plane you get to see kind of other
people's perspectives in like how they
enjoy the games of how they react and
the industry is well aware of his
popularity it's dragging time last year
amazon bought video games streaming site
twitch for 585 million pounds it lets
users watch games being played live and
now YouTube has launched its own service
to try and outplay the competition the
community is a really huge part of what
makes gaming successful on YouTube and
so above all else are our main goal is
how can we how can we address the needs
of that community and grow the community
and engage with community in ways
they're going to produce a really really
interesting thing people are spending
75% more time watching gaming videos
this year compared to last year so that
means stars like Ashley a fast becoming
the next generation of celebrity Chris
Cregan Sky News streaming video gaming
on YouTube is clearly big business in
fact the top five channels have a
combined total of more than 85 million
subscribers and if you don't know which
ones they are is a breakdown for you
let's start at number five British gamer
ksi this 22 year old has well over ten
million subscribers to his channel where
fans watch videos of his mainly FIFA
gameplay and commentary at number four
Spanish star Vegeta 777 who's been up
and running since 2008 in that time he's
racked up nearly 11 million subscribers
with his videos at games like Minecraft
and GTA 5 just a touch ahead his
us-based skydoesminecraft with more than
11.3 million who tuned in to watch
minecraft roleplay custom minigames and
more while at number 2 it vas gaming
real name Evan fall his channel which
includes plenty of comedy has been going
to
boats around 14 million subscribers and
in at number one the success story you
heard about earlier PewDiePie real name
Felix Kjellberg from Sweden the 25 year
old comedian and producer who post
videos of himself playing games has 39
million subscribers that's more than the
entire population of canada and at the
time of recording this week wipe hit hit
just over 10 billion views right time
now to pause the gaming just for a
couple of minutes while we give you a
roundup of some of this week's I love
tech news this is the apples introduced
its iPad pro with an ultra high res
bigger screen and a stylus suitably
named the Apple pencil that's despite
the late chief executive Steve Jobs once
saying nobody wants a stylus the
companies announced its new iphone range
too with 3d touch technology Nintendo is
celebrating 30 years of Super Mario and
it's still going strong with the launch
of new installment Super Mario maker
more on that in our games review later
we've also spoken to the actor behind
the iconic Italian plumbers voice about
why he loves playing the role I get to
see people and the impact of my life and
my work on people that I made them smile
you know they say oh you're the voice of
my childhood oh I love what you do it's
so great thank you so much and and that
itself is such a great honor in such a
great joy because you don't you know if
you're an electrician you know you no
one says oh thanks so much for every
time i plugged in my nightlight my kids
could see their way at night you know
where i plugged it in and every time the
toaster worked way to go buddy but I get
to hear it firsthand and it so you know
what what a profound joy that is let us
introduce you to the swarm this homemade
54 propeller super drone has been
watching up views on YouTube this week
the British engineer behind it says the
project cost him six thousand pounds and
was just a bit of fun
and a smartlock billed as the world's
most advanced launched on a crowdfunding
site this week new CLE lets you use your
phone to see who's at the front door you
can also talk to visitors and lock or
unlock your door remotely we've heard
all about gaming's online star so it's
probably I'm some actual games gotta
mention is our very own star Lucy James
with this week's games review we're
coming up to the 30th anniversary of
Mario who is obviously the most
identifiable plumber in the world he's
been over in over 250 games and Nintendo
a kind of releasing Super Mario maker as
sort of this celebration of Mario it's
also a level creator in one so you can
harness your inner game designer and
create your own Mario levels and as you
work your way through the game you get
more tools for your toolkit and your
levels can become more intricate and you
can then upload them online and share
them with your friends you can download
other ones that people have made and
play them kind of a fantastic way of
celebrating Mario because he's one of
those gaming characters that everyone
has you know some kind of cultural
touchstone with and Mario's such a huge
one so it's no better way to celebrate
his birthday this is ongoing sort of
gaming rivalry between FIFA and pro
evolution soccer and you know in the in
the days of the ps2 in the original xbox
PES was on top and then for the 316 the
ps3 people's on top and now it seems the
tide is turning once again and the PES
is the football simulator game
you needed reminding her part to those
he felt so it's been meeting the same
engine the Fox engine that metal gear
solid 5 phantom pains be made in so the
game looks fantastic which is obviously
very important and they have this new
brand new dynamic weather system so it's
not just you know playing the song of
the time you have that option not only
that controlling it's something that
they iterate on year on you and it's you
know it's snappier it's tighter it's
great to play this year they have got
the European Championships which will be
kind of their big selling point I think
over FIFA which is obviously very
exciting the European football fans
because they get to recognize and place
their favorite teams in PES and on xbox
one we have four to six so 40 is xboxes
it's that car game it is their racing
simulator it's something for you know
really in-depth car fans
selling point mean difference between
that and four to five is that wet
weather driving and it's something that
photo they always go really in-depth on
their research so they've done the
physics they know exactly how a car is
going to act on the wet weather if you
hit a puddle too quickly going to
hydroplane coming back is the drive at
our technology which is quite cool so it
basically the game tracks you as you
play so if you go around a bend for
example and it says perfect it's gonna
log how many times you get those good
scores and build up this online
recreation of you and you can send out
your drivatar to kind of race on your
behalf even when you're not playing and
it earns like points and upgrades and
things also photo has a lot of great
racing sort of legitimacy they have
famous commentator speaking while you're
driving you can play on really famous
race tracks like lemon and the Top Gear
test track makes a return so if you are
a car fan I think Ford's is worth up
that's it for this week see you again
next time for more flight time I went
and joined in yeah
you